Murray Shanahan is a professor of
cognitive robotics at Imperial College
London and a senior research scientist
at deepmind he graduated from Imperial
College with a first in computer science
in 1984 and obtained his PhD from King's
College in Cambridge in 1988. he since
worked in the fields of artificial
intelligence Robotics and cognitive
science he's published books such as
embodiment and the inner life and the
technological singularity his book
embodiment and the inner life was a
significant influence on the film ex
machina for which he was a Scientific
Advisor
now um Professor Shanahan is a renowned
researcher on sophisticated cognition
and its implications for artificial
intelligence his work focuses on agents
that are coupled to complex environments
through sensory motor Loops such as
robots and animals he's also
particularly interested in the
relationship between cognition and
Consciousness and has developed a strong
understanding of the biological brain
and cognitive architectures more
generally in addition Professor Shanahan
is interested in the Dynamics of the
brain including metastability dynamical
complexity and criticality as well as
the application of this understanding to
machine learning he's also fascinated by
the concept of global workspace Theory
as proposed by Bernard bars we'll be
talking about that on the show today
which is based on a cognitive
architecture comprising a set of
parallel specialist processes and the
global workspace Professor Shanahan is
committed to understanding the long-term
implications of artificial intelligence
both its potential and its risk
his research has been published
extensively and he's a member of the
external Advisory board for the
Cambridge Center of the study of
existential risk and also on the
editorial Boards of connection science
and Neuroscience of consciousness
conscious Exotica Professor Shanahan
wrote an article called conscious
Exotica in 2016 where he invited us to
explore the space of possible minds her
concept first proposed by philosopher
Aaron sloman in 1984. now this space is
comprised of all the different forms of
Minds which could exist from those of
other animals such as chimpanzees to
those of life forms that could have
evolved elsewhere in the universe and
indeed those of artificial intelligences
now in order to describe the structure
of this space Shanahan proposes two
Dimensions the capacity for
Consciousness and human likeness of the
behavior
according to Shanahan the space of
possible minds must include forms of
Consciousness that are so alien that we
wouldn't even recognize them he rejects
the dualistic idea that there's an
impenetrable Realm of the subjective
experience remember we were talking
about Nagel's bat on the um the Chalmers
show
insisting instead that nothing is hidden
metaphorically speaking citing
Wittgenstein actually now uh Shanahan
argues that while no artifacts exist
today which has anything even
approaching human-like intelligence the
potential for variation in artificial
intelligences far outstrips the
potential for variation in naturally
evolved intelligence this means that the
majority of the space of possible Minds
may be occupied by non-natural variants
such as the conscious Exotica of which
Shanahan Speaks now ultimately
Shanahan's exploration of the space of
possible Minds invites us to consider
the possibility for human-like minds but
also for those that are radically
different and inscrutable
he concludes that although we may never
understand these alien forms of
Consciousness we can still recognize
them as part of the same reality as our
own
so Professor Shanahan has just dropped a
brand new paper called talking about
large language models in which he
discusses the capabilities and
limitations of large language models now
in order to properly comprehend the
capacities and boundaries of these
models we must first grasp the
relationship between humans and these
systems humans have evolved to survive
in a common world and have cultivated a
mutual understanding reflected in their
ability to converse about convictions
and other mental States conversely AI
systems lack this shared comprehension
so attributing beliefs to them should be
done circumspectly now prompt
engineering is something that we've all
become very familiar with we've
discussed it a lot on this show recently
and it's almost become a fact of the
matter when it comes to these large
language models it involves exploiting
prompt prefixes to adjust the language
models to diverse tasks without needing
any supplementary training allowing for
more effective communication between
humans and machines
nevertheless lacking a more profound
understanding of the system and its
relationship to the external world it's
difficult to be certain whether the
arguments produced by a large language
model a genuine reasoning or simply
mimicry
large language models can be integrated
into a variety of embodied systems even
such as robots or virtual avatars
however this doesn't necessarily mean
that these systems possess completely
human-like language abilities even
though the robot in the seikan system is
physically embodied and interacts with
the real world its language is still
learned and used in dramatically
different manner than humans so in
summary although Professor Shanahan
concludes that large language models are
formidable and versatile they're
fundamentally unlike humans and we must
be wary of ascribing human-like
characteristics to these systems we must
find a way to communicate the nature of
these systems without resorting to
simple terms this may necessitate an
extended period of interaction and
experimentation with the technology but
it's a fundamental step if we are to
accurately portray the capabilities and
limitations of large language models so
anyway without any further delay I give
you professor Murray Shanahan
Professor Shanahan it's an absolute
honor to have you on mlst
tell me a little bit about your
background
my background well I've been interested
in artificial intelligence for as long
as I can remember since I was since I
was a child really and I was very much
drawn to it by science fiction by
science fiction movies and and books and
then I study computer science right from
when I was a teenager and got very much
drawn into programming was fascinated by
programming
um I I really did my 10 000 hours of you
know programming experience when I was
quite quite young then I went on to do
computer science at Imperial College at
London uh that was my degree and then
still fascinated by artificial
intelligence I went on to uh to
Cambridge and did my PhD in AI in in
Cambridge very much in the symbolic
school then
and then I had a long affiliation with
Imperial College did my postdoc there
and still in symbolic AI
and then at some point I became a bit
disillusioned with symbolic Ai and I
kind of segued into um studying the
brain which was the you know the the
obvious example of actual general
intelligence that we that we have
um and uh I think I it was a good 10
years on an Excursion into neuroscience
and computational Neuroscience and that
kind of thing uh and then
um uh and then deep learning and deep
reinforcement learning happened in the
early 2010s and AI started to get
interesting again and I I got very much
back into uh back into it uh that way
and I was particularly
you know impressed by deepminds dqn you
know the system that learned to play
Atari games from scratch and I thought
that was a fantastic step forward and I
really kind of you know went back into
uh went back to my roots and uh back to
AI at that point yeah and I think we'll
talk about dqn when we speak about your
article on on Consciousness but um so
having such a diverse
um you know set of of experiences in in
adjacent Fields how have they influenced
each other
yeah well um and one thing I didn't
mention is that I've also had a
long-standing interest in philosophy and
I I very often
I think that what I am is a sort of
weird kind of philosopher really and
philosophical questions have had a great
attraction for me so I think there's a
kind of you know there's a sort of
three-way interrelationship between uh
artificial intelligence neuroscience and
the other cognitive Sciences
um and and philosophy and I think they
all kind of mutually inform each other
uh really
uh yeah
fantastic so um you wrote a book called
embodiment and the inner life what
motivated you to write that book yeah so
so at that point so that book was
published in uh 2010 and
um it was the culmination of of uh of a
of a sort of long Excursion into
thinking about Consciousness and about
brains
um which you know took place after I had
moved away from symbolic AI really so I
was thinking about uh about the
biological brain in the back of my mind
I'd always been fascinated by these
philosophical questions about
consciousness
uh and then
um uh I went a bit kind of crazy and
started you know uh thinking about these
things seriously it became kind of my
day job to think about neuroscience and
about Consciousness and around about
that time the science of Consciousness
was taking off as a serious you know as
a serious academic discipline with with
proper experimental paradigms so that
was really fascinating
um and I got to know Bernie barrs Bernie
bars is um uh the person who originated
Global workspace Theory Global workspace
Theory being one of the leading
contenders for a scientific theory of
Consciousness
um and I was very drawn to Global
workspace Theory and partly because it
was a computational sort of theory it it
it it drew very heavily on uh computer
science
um and computer architectures there was
a computer architecture at the center of
the of the theory so uh so so so this
kind of collection of of interests along
with my philosophical interests sort of
all came together I wanted to put them
all into a into a book where I expressed
my kind of ideas about first of all from
the philosophical side very heavy
influence of Wittgenstein about how we
address these problems at all
then lots of global workspace Theory and
a certain kind of global workspace
architecture how that might be realized
in the brain drawing also on the work of
Stanislaus de hen who who was working on
what he called the global neuronal
workspace idea and putting all these
things together into you're into one big
book amazing well we'll speak a lot
about wigginstein when we speak about
the the language model paper and your
Consciousness paper but but two things
that did Trigger or prick my ears up
computationalism which is quite
interesting because some some folks in
in the cognitive science Arena
especially with the fouries
um
like
um like examples to escape from
computationalism and we did a show on
cells Chinese room argument the other
day he's probably probably one of the
most known
um people who do issue computationalism
so what do you think about that yeah
well actually so so when I was talking
about global workspace Theory I
mentioned that it it sort of um
comes out of a kind of computational
architecture but in fact where where I
took it uh was very much moving away
from that uh that original presentation
which Drew heavily on a on a kind of
quite a quite an old-fashioned
architectural perspective sort of boxes
and how they communicate with each other
and so on
um and I was much more interested in
taking it in a direction which is very
much more connectionist and
um and drawing much more heavily on the
on the underlying biology and
Neuroscience which in fact is also a
direction that Bernie Barnes himself you
know had moved in because the book that
originally put forward these theories
from 1988 so it's uh you know that was
the the predominant way of thinking at
the time was this very computational
cognitivist perspective
um so by 2010 when my book was published
you know I I was very much
um much more interested in a kind of
more connectionist perspective on things
and um so that's the way that it's
portrayed and in the book for Theory
fascinating because in this Arena some
people cite Penrose and um you know or
the need for hyper computation
um because you know people talk about
the church touring hypothesis and this
idea that the Universe could be made of
information which is quite interesting
but um do you do you believe that the
world that we live in could be
computationally represented and computed
um well I'm not sure that I have a
belief on that particular one
um uh so I mean I I mean penrose's ideas
about consciousness of course draw
heavily on on quantum mechanics and he
thinks that
Quantum effect so you know are important
for for Consciousness but I I mean
that's very much a minority a tiny
minority view within the people who
study Consciousness from a scientific
standpoint and um and uh so I I don't
really subscribe to that point of view I
have to say well I mean coming at it
from a slightly different angle we spoke
to Noam Chomsky recently and I've just
done some content on Nagel's bat a
couple of rationalists and right that
their big argument is about the subject
of experience and um the limits of our
um cognitive Horizon and yeah you know
the the inability really for us to
reduce things into a comprehensible
framework of understanding so how would
you bring that in yeah well gosh I mean
yeah we've launched right into some
really big difficult topics here right
right yeah so so
um
so in my so in my book uh embodiment in
the inner life which you know at the
time I thought I'd really kind of like
wrapped up the problem of Consciousness
you know and uh um but but one of the
big sort of outstanding uh things for me
uh in in that in one of the outstanding
questions that I have not really
answered I felt in in that book is very
much related to to Nagel's question
about uh about bats you know what is it
like to be a bat so
um and it's to do with the idea that
that there's a sort of intuitive idea
that that maybe there can be you know
very exotic entities very exotic uh
creatures who are completely unlike us
and yet somehow there's some kind of
Consciousness there that we could barely
grasp its nature and and this is a you
know it's a sort of natural intuitive
thought and especially when we look at
other animals like bats and especially
if we look at an animal that's a bit
different from us then we you know we
get hints that there's that there's some
someone at home as it were and that
there's consciousness there we I think
you know we I'm sure all of us believe
that cats and dogs you know and uh and
many other animals are are conscious and
are capable of suffering and and you
know have an awareness of the world
that's like our awareness and are aware
of us and each other and and so that's
it I you know I think that's I mean I
take that as almost axiomatic that's
just the way we treat those those
creatures but then when we think about
something like a bat and it's very
different from us so we you know the
natural thing thought is that maybe
maybe what it's like is very very
different from what it's like for us and
it's a natural thought to express
um and um and of course uh you know
Nagel takes that thought
um uh to suggest that there are uh that
there's something that is uh
um inaccessible to us yeah which is you
know what is it like to be a bat is
something we can never know and this is
a very
unconstinian thought and I'm very much
uh uh you know I'm very uh attracted to
to wickenstein's
um philosophy and but but it's also a
very natural thought that you know so
it's a very unfit constitian thought
because wittenstein says for example you
know nothing nothing is hidden so he's
very you know and the whole private
language remarks are all about
sort of saying well this this intuition
that we have that there's this private
realm of experience is actually just we
just it's just it's just a philosophical
trick of the mind to think that this
this sort of peculiar metaphysical realm
exists of inaccessible subjective
experience in in in others yeah and and
that's the that's his whole thrust of
his philosophy or or that you know that
aspect of it is to try and undermine
that so these two things are intention
right so there's this natural thought
that that
but you know it must be like something
to be about but what is it like and how
could we ever know and then there's the
vicenstinian thought which is actually
very difficult to kind of really Embrace
but but it but it's the there's a sense
in which nothing is really
metaphysically hidden it's only hidden
could be hidden empirically because
maybe we don't know enough maybe we
haven't hung around with bats often
enough or maybe we haven't examined
their brains or maybe but that's all
empirical right so there's nothing
metaphysically hidden whereas Nagel's
point is that there's something that's
deeply profoundly philosophically
metaphysically hidden which is
subjective now we can extend that sure
carry on so
um so I'm rambling now so so we can now
we can extend that thought about bats
now you know especially from the
perspective of the sort of thing that
I'm interested in two why not just bats
but what about the whole Space of
possible Minds to use Aaron sloman's
very evocative phrase what about you
know extraterrestrials who are going to
be you know who surely there are there
is extraterrestrial intelligence out
there it's going to be very very very
different to us so and then what about
the things that we built maybe we can
build uh things you know uh and
artificial intelligence of the future
maybe uh maybe you know we can build
something that is also conscious it's
the kind of thing that's depicted in
science fiction all the time in science
fiction it's often depicted as very
human-like but there's no reason why it
should be human alike at all and so we
can imagine these very very exotic
entities and then the question is even
bigger you know there could be something
that we we won't even be able to
recognize that there was even the
possibility of Consciousness but maybe
it's buried there inside this complex
thing somehow so that's the that's the
kind of question that that fascinated me
and I wrote this paper called conscious
Exotica which is all about trying to
trying to make that vicistinian
perspective Encompass this possibility
as well
um yeah yeah and maybe we should talk
about that before the language
um uh paper just because it's it's what
we're talking about now yeah but there's
a few things you said there which were
really interesting so you know when when
um Chomsky talks about ghosts in the
machine and he goes back to Galileo and
and Descartes and actually it was
Descartes who you know introduced this
kind of mind-body dualism and you know
which was
um kind of a move away from the previous
desire to have a mechanistic
understanding of the world that we live
in humans want to understand and
um actually so many things in the world
eludes our understanding and then that
brings us on to
um David Chalmers coined that the hard
problem of Consciousness which I suppose
is an extension of the mind-body problem
and um it's as you were saying this
little bit extra right so we think about
and I agree with traumas that
intelligence and Consciousness are
likely entangled or would co-occur
together but he always said that there's
function Dynamics and behavior and then
there's that little subjected thing on
the top and for charm there's
Consciousness so it's almost like what's
the cash value of it he just thinks it's
just something on top it's not really
requisite for anything else and I
believe it might be requisite for
intentionality and an agency as cell did
but what's your take well it's
interesting because the whole way that
you put that and the whole way that
people often talk about this thing is
you you speak about Consciousness like
there's this thing which you know
there's this singular thing which maybe
it's needed maybe it isn't maybe it's
this maybe it's that but I think that
that whole way of of talking is is uh
which is which is natural for us in many
everyday situations but when it comes to
this kind of conversation I think that
whole way of talking is maybe not quite
right because we're we're thinking of
Consciousness as this you know we're
reifying it turning it into this thing
whereas I think maybe we at that point
we have to take a step back and we have
to say well
when we talk about when we use that word
conscious or Consciousness so we use it
in all kinds of different ways in
different contexts and so when we talk
about you know we might talk about it uh
in the context of an animal we might say
well this this the animal you know this
this dog is aware of its environment so
the way you know this dog can see the uh
the the bowl in front of it it can see
me it can see the door it can see the
trees it can see the squirrel you know
and and it can smell they're more likely
to smell all of these things as well so
so so we use Consciousness you know we
talk about Consciousness in that that
sense and we also talk about our
self-consciousness you know we talk
about the fact that we're you know we're
aware of our own thoughts and and we we
talk about our inner life and and we use
Consciousness to to Encompass that as
well
we we often use Consciousness in the
context in scientifically but of a
distinction between
conscious and unconscious processes and
that's a very interesting distinction
because when uh we're consciously aware
of a stimulus as humans then a whole lot
of things come together our uh we're
able to kind of like deal with novelty
better we're able to report it we're
able to remember things better so so
whereas when we perhaps uh are
unconsciously or there's a kind of
unconscious processing of a stimulus
then we still can respond to it
behaviorally but
um and it can have cueing effects and so
on but it doesn't have all those other
things so this and and that's kind of
there's a kind of Integrative
um function for Consciousness there and
then on top of all of that there is
um uh the capacity for suffering and joy
that comes with so so often there's a
there's uh there's valence to
Consciousness you know there's there's
so that's another thing so all of these
things they come as a package in humans
but when we speak about edge cases then
all then then they these things come
apart I mean need to speak about them
separately I think fascinating I mean
there are two um kind of minor
digressions there I mean that you were
talking about these planes of
Consciousness which is also very
interesting and maybe we could get into
the um integrated information Theory or
the global workspace Theory just just
for the for the audience just to give
them some context yeah sure uh or Jordan
we say a few words about oh please yeah
yeah okay uh yeah so there's so there
are a number of kind of candidates for
um for a scientific theory of
Consciousness uh and you just mentioned
two of the leading ones which are Global
workspace Theory and integrated
information uh Theory and so Global
Works based Theory so that's that's
Bernie Barr's uh was originated by
Bernie bars and has been developed by
Stanislas dehen and colleagues so the
idea there is it's it does rest on this
sort of architectural idea which is that
um
uh which is that we think of of the
brain the biological brain as comprising
you know a very large number of parallel
processes this is kind of a natural way
to think of a brain a large number of
parallel processes and it and the global
Works based Theory posits a particular
way in which these these processes
interact and communicate with each other
and that is via This Global workspace
and the idea there is that
um is that there are sort of two modes
of processing that that go on so in one
mode of processing
um the these parallel processes just do
their their own thing independently and
in the other mode of processing they are
working via This Global workspace Theory
so the idea is that they uh you might
think of them as as you know depositing
messages if you like in This Global
workspace which are then broadcast out
to all of the other processes so so it's
so there's this kind of but I think
thinking of in terms of messages is not
quite the right way of thinking of it is
better to think in terms of kind of
signaling and information and so on but
that's in that sort of natural way to
think of it but so the so these so in in
that mode the these processes are uh
sort of disseminating their influence to
all the other processes and that's the
global kind of broadcast
um aspect of it and that's when
Consciousness uh well that's when
information processing is conscious
according to Global workspace Theory as
opposed to when it's all just local and
the processes of doing their own thing
that's that's not that that processing
is not conscious so there's a distance
so it's about teasing out this
distinction between conscious
information processing and unconscious
information processing now all of those
terms by the way are deeply
philosophically problematic and to go in
you know you to sort of do it properly
you have to kind of unpack them all in
very carefully and that's what my book
try tries to do but so essentially it's
about it so the the essential idea
though is to do with broadcast and
dissemination of information throughout
the brain and going from like local
processes and them having global
influence and that's why Consciousness
is all about according to Global
workspace Theory
okay so integrated information Theory
so I think so integrated information
Theory which is Julio tanoni's uh uh uh
Theory
um which giulio tanoni uh thinks this is
is kind of kind of incompatible in some
ways with uh with global workspace
Theory but I don't think that's that's
true I think I think that there's a lot
of
um Synergy between the two theories in
fact
um uh but but that's because they so
they come
um with so to integrated information
Theory
has sort of two aspects to it so so
according to giulio tanoni he really is
trying to pin down a property
um uh which is almost like a physical
property which is identical with
Consciousness so you can actually speak
about the amount of Consciousness in any
system that you that you look out Phi
this is Phi so the Phi is a number how
is actually a number of how much
Consciousness is present in the system
like like part of your brain or your
whole brain or you as a person or a
flock of bats or whatever so you can or
or a toaster you know so you can give a
number to how much Consciousness there
is there is there according to his
theory and it's a mathematical Theory
based on Shannon's information Theory
and it's but it and but it's all about
um trying to see how much information is
processed by the individual parts of the
system versus how much information is
processed by all of the parts put
together and it's it's and it's to do
with how much the second thing you know
exceeds the first thing and and in a
sense and that is how much Consciousness
there is there and um and and in a way
it it actually has some synergies if you
as long as you don't think that it's
necessarily measuring uh you know this
property of the of the universe which
you can put a number on but it has some
synergies with global workspace Theory
because they're they're both
distinguishing between Global holistic
things versus local uh things and the
and the Consciousness is in the kind of
global holistic processing uh versus the
local uh you know local processing in
both those theories so there's a kind of
you know there's some intuitions that
they have in common I think interesting
and um it also reminds me a little bit a
little bit about what Chalmers um speaks
about so he he thinks that it strongly
emerges from certain types of
information processing and um the the
processing must represent causal
structures as well so it can't it's it's
not an appeal to pan psychism say and
although with with all of the the things
that you've just spoken about
um what do they work in Another Universe
I mean I guess what I'm saying is is it
just the
um the physical and the information
processing or in a different Universe
might it not emerge in the same way yeah
it depends what you mean by a different
Universe I guess what do you mean by a
different Universe well if the laws of
nature were different yeah okay so if
the laws of physics were were different
um well I guess my I guess I
I dislike isms I'm I'm I'm an
anti-islamist or rather I'd say I'm not
an ismist
um but if I were to I but I do sort of
subscribe broadly to functionalism I
suppose so I I guess uh I guess I
but what do I mean by that I mean what I
mean
is
I mean I I really dislike saying that I
subscribe to these to these isms so what
I really mean by that is that
um uh is that I imagine that a system
that is organized in a particular way
functionally in terms of its information
processing and if that system is in is
embodied in the broadest sense uh and
you know and meets lots of other
prerequisites then it's likely to behave
in a way where I'm going to naturally
use the word conscious to describe it
perhaps and where I'm going to treat it
like a fellow conscious creature so um
so so it's so you know ultimately it's I
think it's about the kind of
organization you need to give rise to
the behavior you need to talk about
thing the thing in a certain way my
question to think is I posed this
question to Chalmers last week he's also
a functionalist and and I I agree with
the degree of functionalism describing
intelligence but less so with with
Consciousness you know there's not a
Turing test for Consciousness for
example but but the thing is with
functionalism I we're at risk of doing
what you said people do with large
language models which is
anthropomorphizing them because these
functions are intelligible to us and
then our conception of intelligence
becomes somewhat Observer relative
um
yes do I I mean what I observe a
relative so
um you understand these functions so
it's conscious to you but not to someone
else
uh well
um so so so in all of these cases um I
mean I think it's about the the words
that we use in our language to talk
about the things so the the so so if the
someone else is someone just like us
right then then we have to and if we
want to use the words in different ways
so so the large language models are a
great case in point right so so suddenly
we're arriving
at a point where somebody can describe
something as conscious
um and others can say that's rubbish you
know it's not that's not true at all and
so we so we've we've arrived at a point
where these philosophically problematic
Words which uh which we use in in
ordinary life quite quite harmlessly and
we all you know we all are in agreement
about how we use the word like so if
somebody says oh you know Fred has drank
so much last night he passed out he was
completely unconscious you know and we
and or if in anesthetist says yes you
know the patient is now unconscious they
can't feel feel pain
um or if you say oh um you know I I just
wasn't aware I didn't see the uh the
cyclist you know that's why I I hit them
you know I'm really it's tragic but I
just didn't see them and then and we so
you know so he said I wasn't aware of it
so it didn't influence my action so they
were using the terms in ways that we all
understand but now we're getting to a
point where suddenly these words or
these concepts are being used you know
we don't have a way we don't have
agreement about how to use these words
right because it's there's there are
these exotic edge cases yes so then the
question I think that you you're getting
it is you know is is there a fact of the
matter there right and
um so I'm very tempted to say the first
thing I'm tempted to say is that I don't
think that perhaps is a fact of the
matter or certainly I don't I don't want
to I don't want to speak as if there is
a fact of the matter but rather I think
we need to arrive at a new consensus
about how we use these words so that
might mean that we extend the words we
break them apart like I was suggesting
earlier maybe we need to separate out uh
awareness of the world from
self-awareness from integration
cognitive integration from the capacity
for suffering because suddenly we have
things that where that they don't all
come as a package and when we need to
kind of be a bit more nuanced in the way
that we use these words we need to use
them in new ways but then there's a kind
of transition period because we don't
you know we're we're all arguing about
how to use these words all of a sudden
because we've got weird edge cases so
there's going to be a time when it'll
take a time for language to settle back
down again so there's a kind of you know
there's a kind of Observer relativeness
to this for a bit if you like but then
but then there's a kind of consensus
needs to to emerge right but
um there's so many things to explore
them you know I'm I would love it if
this platonic idea of of Concepts were
possible and um
because what we're talking about here is
reductionism and the I mean the parable
of the blind man and the Elephant comes
in quite nicely so as Chomsky said
complex phenomenon beyond our cognitive
Horizon and as much as we don't want to
we use functions derived from Behavior
to have some common understanding of
this thing but I wasn't being
reductionist was I do you think I was
being reductionist well well no so you
said the language game converges and and
um in some cases we will arrive on on a
common definition but like you can bring
in hofstatter as well well not common
definition but a common usage right so
we'll we'll come so we'll come to use
the words you know in with agreement
right so that's what I and the reason
why I mean I would and I worry the
reason I would bulk at using the word
reductionist is because uh and that's
why I'm a bit listen to functionalism as
well for any kind of ism is because I I
just think that that maybe the way
things are are organized when you take
them apart so you know uh
brains right because when you examine
them on the inside like animal brains
you might look at how an octopus's brain
works and that might inform whether you
think that It suffers can experiences
pain or not or we might break apart you
know an AI of a system of the future
right you know and we might break it
apart and we may look at its functional
organization and that all is just is
Grist to the mill of how our language
might change right so I'm not I'm not
subscribing to the fact that
Consciousness is this or this is that
with some big metaphysical capital
letters on the is right that's really
important
um so so that so the organize the
functional organization of these other
things which when we study it and look
at it is all just part becomes part of
the conversation that eventually is
going to help us to settle on maybe new
ways of talking about these things I I
think we agree with it with each other I
think the difference is so with the
parable of the Blind Men and the
Elephant all of the men around the
elephant
um saw something which was part of the
truth truth yeah and I think that's what
we're describing with the function so we
can all agree on what perception means
or what um action means yeah but the
thing is there will be many other
functions that will represent a
different slice of that cognitive
phenomenon yeah I agree and I think
that's very much true with Consciousness
actually because there's lots of people
come in with kind of like new ideas and
new uh theories I mean you know uh anal
Seth for example have you had animal on
your on your not yet being used right so
Daniel's written this great book called
being you yeah
um and and and annel brings in a whole
kind of new set of ideas he's
particularly uh uh interested in uh you
know you know the sort of top-down
effects of on on perception top-down
effects on perception so then he brings
in this kind of top-down influence and
perception as a big part of things and
then there's Graziano has written this
book using this about his attention
schema uh theory of of Consciousness and
um and that's and you know there's a
whole set of interesting ideas there and
I think you're absolutely right I think
there's I I think there's aspects of all
of these things all feed into
you know all feed into
um the way you know
brains and animals uh work and all of
them feed into the
um you know why they behave the way they
do and why we use those words when we
use those words you know conscious and
aware and so on fascinating we'll get to
your article in a second but
um as someone who has such a a diverse
and interesting background who is
allowed to ask these philosophical
questions it reminds me um uh Thomas
meckinsey was talking about the
arguments between neuroscientists and
philosophers about freedom of the will
yeah and who who gets to decide huh yeah
well what a great question you know I
mean so why should I have any right to
speak about any of these things at all
because I have no formal training in
philosophy
um so uh so so who gets to who gets to
this well who gets to to I guess there
are two things right there's I guess I
guess there's there's in in that kind of
discussion between the neuroscientists
and and the philosophers so there you
there you're not talking about you know
the everyday conversation that we're all
having as as Humanity or as English
speakers or as Chinese speakers about
how we use these these these words so
there it's a much more kind of confined
to the to to different two different
schools or disciplines within Academia
so there I mean I do think that
um uh that people who work in Ai and in
and in Neuroscience probably at least
should be a bit familiar with the with a
philosophical debates and you know you
mentioned Descartes earlier on and you
know you're familiar with with just that
that basic kind of you know sort of uh
uh stuff that which is like philosophy
101 which people should at least be
aware of Descartes arguments and then
Chalmers and their different kind of
perspectives on those sorts of things
before they pitch in you know at least I
mean you wouldn't pitch into
Neuroscience just by making some up some
stuff about brains if you hadn't read
you know the an introduction to
neuroscience and so so I think that the
scientists need to
um you know uh uh you know they need to
kind of have a pass to enter the
conversation to have to have got through
philosophy 101 yeah it's so true we have
the same thing with the um with the
ethics folks actually because we have a
lot of fields of expertise and Engineers
should learn more about ethics yeah
absolutely but when they do have an
opinion about ethics quite quite often
it it's it's
um you can sometimes be a bit naive and
uh and and you know at least you should
be familiar with the kind of um but but
that's an interesting and a difficult
error in itself because of course
um you know you uh as a scientist it's
important that you take responsibility
as a scientist and and the and that you
take you know some ethical
responsibility but at the same time you
know you've only got so much time to
become an expert so so it's difficult to
at the same time
take ethical responsibility
um uh and yet you know even though
perhaps you haven't got the time to kind
of uh read you know uh you know read up
and become an expert on the relevant
ethics so I mean perhaps everybody again
should you know get to the entry level
you know ethics 101 and indeed many many
courses teach you know ethics uh these
days many kind of science and computer
science it's part of you know of any
degree these days so that's a good step
I think yeah there's an interesting
analogy between the functionalism that
we're speaking about in Consciousness I
mean even in our own research domain we
have the function of ethics and we have
linguists and we have all sorts of
different people yeah and and that is
the Blind Men in the elephant and you
know I tend to believe that even though
the the views from these diverse folks
are inconsistent diversity is very
important oh incredibly important
intellectual diversity is you know every
kind of diversity is important and
intellectual diversity is immensely
important and having these conversations
is interdisciplinary conversations is
absolutely you know essential so at
least if people are talking to each
other that's a really really uh positive
thing I think fantastic now we invited
Chalmers on our podcast after Ilya Suds
together's tweet and by the way Chalmers
took a very functionalist approach to
talking about Consciousness that um uh I
I guess after that tweet everyone in the
community started thinking about and
talking about Consciousness so yeah
maybe let's just start from that tweet
how did you find it sure yeah okay so
the Tweet was so so Ilya suzukivar said
uh said it may be that today's large
language models are slightly conscious
um and uh and then then I rep replied uh
tweeted back in the same sense that it
that maybe a large field of wheat is
slightly pasta and uh and and that in
fact was it was actually
um I mean I've got a fair number of
Twitter followers and but that was the
most engaged tweet I've ever sent out
um and uh you know uh and you know it
got celebrity likes Hannah fried
retweeted it and you know it only is
um uh my kind of uh comment
um and uh uh so so but that does kind of
um summarize sort of what I think about
about what he said at that point
um uh but then but then I after tweeting
my my flippant response I then I was
violating all my own Twitter rules in in
just sending back a a flippant response
because
I generally don't do that I I would
rather kind of uh you know be
professional engaged professionally and
so I thought it's very important to
follow that on with a you know with a
little explanation of why you know uh
why I thought that it wasn't really
appropriate to speak about today's large
language models in those terms yeah
um and for me the number one thing is to
do with embodiment
um so
um so as I see it embodiment is a kind
of prerequisite for uh for us being able
to use that that word use words like
Consciousness and so on you know in the
way that we do in the normal everyday uh
way of talking so so uh you know it's
only in the presence of something
um uh that that inhabits our world and
buying habits I don't mean just has a
physical you know like a computer is
obviously a physical thing in our world
but inhabits our world means that you
know walks around you know how swims or
jumps or flies or whatever but is is is
inhabits the same world as us and
interacts with it and and is and uh uh
and you know and and interacts with the
objects in it and with other uh um with
other
uh creatures like ourselves so so that
to my mind that is that's the that so so
uh so in that paper conscious Exotica I
think I use this phrase channeling
Wittgenstein that that only in the
context of something that
um that exhibits purposeful Behavior do
we speak of Consciousness and the way
that's that's phrased I mean there is
kind of you know so trying to channel
wittgenstein's style of of of saying
things because you notice he's saying
that it's only he's making what he's
saying is actually he's talking about
the way we use the word so he's not
making a metaphysical claim this is
essential he's saying that this is just
this is these are the circumstances
under which we use this word so we use
this word in the context of fellow
creatures basically
and so um so that's the kind of the
starting point so a large and of course
we of course we talk to people on the
telephone and over the internet and so
on and we don't you know we may not we
you know we can't see them or anything
so we but but we but we still we know
that there is
um uh you know or we assume we've always
been able to assume up to this point
that there is a fellow creature at the
other end and that's the kind of
grounding for kind of
thinking that way and using that using
that word now that is absent in large
language models so large language models
do not inhabit the world that we do yeah
and um
uh now I mean we have to caveat that
because of course it's possible to embed
a large language model in a in a in a
well in we always do embed it in a
larger system it might be a very simple
embedding it might be just a chat bot or
it might be much more complicated like
it might be be part of a system that uh
enables a robot to kind of move around
and interact with the world and take
instructions and and so on
um
um so there was a great some great work
from Google with uh Palm say can robot
for example where there's this embedded
large language model so so there you're
kind of moving in a in a direction where
maybe uh where these were these words
you know uh the prerequisites uh you
know for for
well actually I won't be careful what I
say here sorry
because it's so easy to say something
that's going to can be misinterpreted
right but but we can't imagine uh that
that we can't imagine that requirement
being met for for not not it doesn't
mean it wouldn't be a a sufficient
condition for using those words but at
least it would you'd meet the necessary
conditions right but the large language
models uh by themselves do not me even
they're not even candidates yes I I
agree and we there's so many things we
can do here because we can we can talk
about embodiment in general I mean as I
understand it Rodney Brooks kind of
um started the phenomenon of thinking
about a representationalist view of
artificial intelligence or uh embodied
rejecting a website rejecting yeah so so
Rodney Brooks thought that we should use
the world as its own best representation
which is absolutely fascinating yeah and
and then you you maybe you might be
thinking about the embodiment view
um in a similar style of Wittgenstein so
it's a matter of complexity and it's
also a matter of encapsulation which is
fascinating but but also just to create
your paper you said although the
language model component of seikan
provides natural language descriptions
of low-level actions it doesn't take
into account what the environment
actually affords the robot so there's
this whole affordance thing as well so I
mean how do you think about embodiment
so so the way I see it is that the the
is that the uh you know the one Exemplar
we have uh as of you know the end of
2022 of something that we really can
describe as in as as intelligent as
generally intelligent uh is is the
biological brain biological brains of of
humans but also of other animals
and the biological brain uh you know at
its very uh it's very kind of nature is
it's there to help a creature to move
around in the world to move right it's
there to move help to guide a a a
creature and help it move in order to
help it survive and reproduce that's
what brains are for so that's what that
from an evolutionary point of view
that's that they they developed in order
to uh help a creature to move and they
are so they they and and they are uh you
know they're the bit that comes between
this the sensory input and the motor
output and as far as you can cleanly
divide these things which maybe you
can't but I mean um so and so that
that's that that's their purpose is to
intervene in the sensory motor Loop in a
way that benefits the organism and
everything else is on built on top of
that so uh so so the capacity to to
recognize objects in our environments
and and categorize them and the the
ability to kind of manipulate objects in
the environment pick them up and so on
and all of that is there you know
initially to help the the the organism
to survive and um uh and and you know
and that's what
um Brains Brains are there for and then
then when it comes to like you know uh
the ability to work out how the world
works and to to do things like figure
out how to gain access to some item of
food that's difficult to get hold of
then all kinds of cognitive capabilities
might be required to understand how you
get inside a uh you know a a shell or
something to get it at the the the fruit
inside it or something like that complex
cognitive abilities that so that and
then you know evolutionary Evolution has
developed a lot of more and more and
more complex cognition until we get to
language and you know we need to
interact with each other because that
that's all very much a part of it the
social social side of it and then
language is part of that so as I see it
it's all built on top of uh this
fundamental fact of our of the
embodiment of of the animal and the
organism so that's in the biological
case so that's the sort of our starting
point so um
uh and so that seems to me to be the the
most natural way to to understand the
very nature of intelligence the guitar
frame is I think I didn't I didn't frame
it very well I mean Melanie Mitchell
recently had a paper out talking about
the four misconceptions and one of them
of course citing Drew McDermott was The
Wishful mnemonics and the
anthropomophization which which you've
basically spoken about but um but her
fourth one was about embodiment and and
she spoke about this in her book as well
and she said that one of the
misconceptions of AI is that people have
this notion of a pure intelligence you
know something which works in isolation
yeah environment and you're talking
about social embeddedness and embodiment
and I guess my point with the complexity
argument is I'm saying that the brain
itself doesn't actually do everything it
kind of works as part of a bigger system
oh I see what you mean yes okay yeah
yeah so there's
um uh so of course there's I mean
um I noticed in one of your previous
interviews with Andrew lampin and you
mentioned the three E's Frameworks yeah
four East these days
um uh and as of course that's very much
part part of it is the is the idea that
you know there's the extended mind we
use the environment uh uh you know as as
a kind of memory for example for uh we
we deposit things in the environment
writing you know is an example and so on
um and then there's
um people talk about morphological
computation I'm sure you've you're
familiar with that so no well so that's
the idea that the very shape of our
bodies uh you know is is is uh is you
know could so so so sometimes you know
the aspects of of intelligence are
actually out short outsourced into the
physical shape of of your body so where
you might think about designing a robot
where you where where you put a lot of
work into the control aspect of it so
that it so that it kind of kind of walk
in this very carefully engineered ways
that it's always permanently stable or
alternatively you can make a body that
is naturally sort of uh stable or maybe
naturally stable and what you do is you
kind of rely on the combination of the
physics of it constantly falling with uh
with a control system that constantly
restores balance so that so so you know
so it so that's that's a I mean this is
very much a Brooks type perspective and
and people picked up on Brooks's uh
ideas and extended them in this sort of
way so I think that's I think that's a
very natural uh way of thinking but in a
way that this gets to the to the
complexity argument because I guess what
I'm saying is that
um
life is much more brittle than anyone
realizes you were just pointed to some
sources of brittleness that most people
never would have thought of which is
which is fascinating so I think there's
a very important relationship between
embodiment and language uh and this also
brings us back to Wittgenstein as well
so
um uh so if for us as humans language is
inherently an embodied phenomenon it's
it's it's something that is uh it's a
social practice uh something that take
that that is a phenomenon that
um occurs in the context of other
language users who inhabit the same
world as we do and where we have kind of
like joint activities we're
triangulating on the same world and
we're we're acting on the same world
together and that's the that's what
we're talking about when we use language
so there's this uh so that that's an
inherently conviction view of language I
mean and I think it's deeply profoundly
correct a view of of language that's
that's what that's what language is
there for us is so that we can talk
about the same things together so that
we can our Collective activity is is
um you know is is organized
um to some extent thanks to language
so that's uh so I think that's a really
important perspective uh on languages
for kingstonian perspective and
embodiment is at the heart of it
embodiment and inhabiting the same world
uh as our other language users
um and you know that's the way we learn
language we learn language
um by being around other language users
like our parents and carers and and and
and and
peers uh and and that's again a very
important aspect of the of the nature of
human language now large language models
um they learn language in a very
different way indeed they do not inhabit
the same world as us they do not kind of
sense the world in the way that we do
they don't learn language from uh from
other language users from their peers in
the way that we do
um but rather you know we know how large
language
models work there's trained on a very
very large Corpus of textual of textual
data so an enormous Corpus of textual
data so bigger than any human is likely
to encounter you know you know by the
time they become a proficient language
user at a young age
um and what they're trying to do is is
um is not to kind of uh engage in
activities with other language users but
to predict what the next you know what
the next token is going to be which is a
very very different sort of thing so
they're very very different sorts of
things and the and the role of
embodiment is really really important in
this different setting
yes um absolutely when I spoke with
Andrew lampanam um he's really really
interested in the grounding problems I
mean would you mind just speaking about
that a little bit before we go into your
paper yeah absolutely yeah yeah
um so of course this goes goes back to a
a great paper by Stephen harned back in
I think 1999 or 1998 so the one and only
yeah the one and only uh on this the
symbol grounding problem it was called
and uh and and you know he does um argue
broadly that
um uh that Sim symbols in in AI systems
um the kinds of AI systems he was
thinking about at the time were kind of
you know sort of expert system say or
something like that and the symbols
there are not grounded they're provided
by the human programmers and they've
just sort of typed in whereas for us for
us the words we use those symbols are
are grounded in uh in our activity in
the world so that when we use the word
dog that's because we've seen dogs and
we've talked about dogs with other
people who've also seen dogs and we've
seen dogs in lots of different
circumstances and we've also seen cats
and and uh and and dog bowls and bones
and many other things that all kind of
contextualize that but all of that that
that is kind of grounded in the real
world and now and in our perception of
the things in question so that so that's
this so that's what sort of is meant by
grounding although at least that's the
original meaning of the word grounding
from Stephen harnett's paper yeah and I
think that's a really really important
um concept because uh because uh you
know in in an important sense large
language models the symbols that are
used in larger language models are not
really grounded in that kind of way now
this you know I should be absolutely
clear that large language models are
immensely powerful and immensely useful
and and and so that you know so but it's
interesting that to what to what extent
the lack of grounding here
that we have in today's large language
models you know might uh affect uh how
good they are so um so they you so they
are prone to kind of you know uh
hallucinating and and and confabulating
and uh and if you look at
um multi-modal language models that
maybe we'll talk about an image that you
present to them uh then you know they
you can have a very interesting
conversation but sometimes they'll go
off piste and start talking about things
that are not in the image at all and as
if they are and um and that's sort of
because due to a kind of I was a lack of
grounding there's so that so the the
words are not kind of grounded in the
images in in quite the way that we would
like so that's it's an important topic
of research I think yes indeed and
although some people do believe there's
this magical word called emergence and
possibly some emergent symbol grounding
might be possible maybe should we just
put that to bed before we introduce you
on yeah sure well uh well I mean
emergencies is I I think is uh is a
really important concept and I yeah and
I think you know we do see a tremendous
amount of of uh very powerful emergence
I think in today's large large language
models so so so uh you know even though
the the so they're basically trained to
do next word prediction or I mean
obviously to be clear I suppose I should
have made this maybe a bit clearer in
the paper but of course it's not always
next word prediction because there are
different models learn to actually uh
you know predict what's in the middle of
a of a sequence rather than kind of but
generally you know they're interested in
in in in in
let's take the next word prediction
cases canonical so so there so so
they're so they're trained to just to do
next word prediction now the astonishing
thing is as I think gpt3 showed us
um is that is that just that capability
if it's sufficiently powerful can be
used to do all sorts of extraordinary
things because uh if you provide uh you
know the a prompt that describes you
know describes some kind of complicated
thing uh you know situation like uh you
know I I need to
um uh tile my floor and my floor is
shaped like an l and it's 20 meters long
and three meters and well you know you
start to describe this and you know in
each each tile is is is 20 centimeters
square how many tiles will I need and
and some large language model will come
back and tell you you need 426 tiles
whatever and it's correct right well
this is astonishing because it was only
trained to do next word prediction and
so there's a kind of emergent capability
there now there's a sense of course in
which it still is just doing next word
prediction because in the vast and
immensely complex distribution of tokens
in human text that's that's that that's
out there then the correct answer is
actually the thing that's most likely to
come up and that's but it's got to
discover a mechanism for produce that
right and so that is where the emergence
comes in and it I think the the you know
the these capacities are astonishing the
fact that they that it can discover
mechanisms you know uh emergently that
will do that sort of thing yes and maybe
I shouldn't have used the word magic
with it with emergence I I'm a huge fan
of emergence and and as you say the the
decode is trained to predict the next
token or the denoising autoencoders to
to let's say fill in the gaps in in the
middle and I guess there are different
ways of thinking about emergence so
there's weak emergence which might be
thought as computational irreducibility
or a surprising macroscopic change or
strong emergence when it's not directly
deducible from troops and the low level
domain you know
exactly but I guess my point is that
remarkably it's trained on something
quite trivial so all of this is about
convention right all of this is about
what's what what is the what is a good
way to use words right so I don't so I
don't think uh you know I'm not making
metaphysical claims about about about
these things so it's all about what you
know when is it appropriate to use words
to use certain words and and because
when this becomes problematic is when
they're philosophically difficult words
like beliefs and thinks and so on
um now when it comes to reasoning uh so
so I I do think that we I do think it's
not unreasonable to to to use that term
to describe what some of the these
models do today and that's partly
because of the content neutrality of of
uh of of reasoning so so uh so so a lot
of the argument
um a lot of the discussion in the paper
comes back to this sort of whole
embodiment thing really
um and and I'm I'm saying well you know
in in the kind of like ordinary way we
use the word believes well it's gets it
gets complicated because we do use the
word believes uh in this intentional
starts way to to talk about ordinary
everyday things we say oh my my you know
my my car clock thinks that it's a
British summer time you know ah you know
and because we and then but then you'd
say then you somebody says to you but
you you mean your your car clock can
think you say you know obviously I
didn't mean that it can think it's just
a turn of phrase you know but when we
when we get to these large language
models and we start to use the words
like thinks and and beliefs and so on
because they're so powerful it starts to
get a bit ambiguous and you're and
you're and you know when and some people
say well actually I really did mean that
it can think or that it believes so I'm
so I'm I'm interested in this when
things get difficult in this respect and
um could could you tease apart though so
you resist anthropomorphic language in
terms of belief knowledge understanding
self or even Consciousness yeah but less
so with reasoning and I my intuition is
that reasoning rather depends on those
things that I just said before well I um
so I think it doesn't because
um uh but but this is but perhaps this
is just uh maybe in a kind of formal
logic sense because because reason
because logic is content neutral so if I
tell you that everything could you just
explain what you mean by that okay so um
so Lewis Carroll has all these wonderful
kind of like nonsense syllogisms right
where he where
um uh you know he says oh if all
elephants
um like custard and you know Jonathan is
an elephant you know then Jonathan likes
custard and you know all kinds of things
like that and it's all sort of nonsense
and he has this big complex complicated
ones and similarly I could tell you that
uh all all uh sprogforths are plingy and
uh and Juliet is a sprogforth therefore
Juliet is is splingy right and I've no
idea what any of those things mean but
the the but it's because it because it
for the pure form of the reasoning you
don't have to know what they mean it's
just about the the logic so
um so in that sense you know
um uh it just in the way that a fear
improver can do logic then then so can a
large language model do logic so in that
sense I think largely it is reasonable
to use the word reasoning in that
logical sense in the context of large
language models I don't think that's a
problem of course we may think that they
do it badly or they do it well or that's
a whole other thing right but but at
least the word is
potentially applicable right yes our
belief I think you know I think at the
moment is a is a is a different kettle
of fish because to really uh have a hold
of belief it's it it's not content
neutral right so if you if I believe to
use the example in my in my paper
if I believe that uh Burundi is to the
south of of of Rwanda well whether that
is the case or not it does depend upon
facts that are out there in the world
and then to to Really uh have a belief
at least you've got to be able to uh
somehow try and kind of justify justify
those facts or at least and you've got
to be at least built in such a way that
you can you know interact with the
external world and do that sort of thing
right and and verify that something is
true or false or do an experiment or you
know or or ask someone or you know
you've got to go outside yourself right
we go outside of ourselves and and in
order to establish whether something a
belief is true or not and so you've got
to at least be capable of doing that
whereas large language models The Bare
Bones large language model is not
capable of doing that at all right now
you can embed it in a larger system this
is a really important distinction that I
try and make over and again in the paper
I talk about the Bare Bones large
language model so you can take the so
any whenever a large language model is
used it's not the Bare Bones large
language model which just does sequence
prediction but it's embedded in a larger
system when we embed it in a large
system well that larger system maybe
could consult Wikipedia maybe it could
be part of a robot that goes and
investigates the world so that's a whole
other thing but then you have to look at
each case in point and and and ask
yourself whether it's a whether you know
whether we really want to use that word
in it in in Anger you know as in in its
full sense rather than just in the
intentional stance sense of a kind of
figure of speech so and so in the case
of of like chat Bots for example
um today's chat Bots not really
appropriate I would say we're not using
the word in the way that we in the
full-blown sense that we use it when we
talk about each other fascinating okay
well let's get on to intentional stance
so you said that it's a useful way of
thinking about artificial intelligence
allowing us to view computer programs as
intelligent agents even though they may
lack the same kind of understanding as a
human and you cited the case of Bob and
Bot the the word no was used differently
in the two cases and the word of Bob it
was used in the traditional sense for
bot it was used in the metaphorical
sense so it kind of like it's just
distinguishing what it means uh to know
you know for humans and and for machine
so I think it's uh it's useful to think
about something like Wikipedia so
um so we might ask the question does
Wikipedia know that Argentina has won
the 2022 World Cup and just immediately
after the event you know it probably
doesn't it's not recorded in Wikipedia
and somebody might say oh Wikipedia
doesn't know yet that that Argentina of
one and so when we use the a word like
that you know nobody's going to kind of
say to them say to somebody who uses
that word um uh hey you know I don't
think you should use the word nose there
or you know you know you should be a bit
more sort of sensible I mean that's it's
fine to kind of use I think these kinds
of uh words in this ordinary Mary
everyday sense so we do that all the
time and that sort of um uh and
particularly particularly in the case of
computers that's adopting what dandenic
calls the intentional starts so we're so
we're we're interpreting something as as
as as having beliefs desires and
intentions
um uh because it's a kind of convenient
shorthand and especially if you've got
something that's a bit more complicated
like say your car's Sat Nav or something
or you're you're you know you're Sat Nav
when you're on your phone then it sort
of makes makes sense to use those words
it is a convenient shorthand and it
helps us to kind of um talk about them
right and without
getting overly complicated and without
knowing the underlying mechanisms but
there's an important sense in which we
don't mean it literally so you know in
the case of Wikipedia you can't you
couldn't go up to Wikipedia and Pat it
on the shoulder and say hey Argentina
have won and there's no way you know
right I want to be a you know in uh and
and all and all the things that that go
with us as humans actually knowing
things and uh
it's just a turn of phrase now things
get sort of interesting with large
language models and with large language
model based systems and the kinds of
things that we're starting to see in in
the world because we're starting to get
into this kind of blurry territory where
it where we're blurring between the
intentional stance and and you know
meaning the meaning it literally and
this is where we need to be really
really kind of careful I think so at
what point does do things shade over
into where it's legitimate to use that
word uh you know uh literally in the in
the context of something that they've
built you know I I don't think we're at
that point yet and we need to be very
careful about
um
about
uh using the word as if we were using it
literally uh you know that's the sort of
anthropomorphization because the problem
is that we can then
um impute capacities to the thing and
and and or even you know empathy say
that that just isn't there yes and I
suppose we could tease apart knowledge
so a Justified true belief from nose
because knows that it brings all this
baggage of intentionality and agency and
anthropomorphization but you heard
Chomsky you've had Chomsky on there I
could tell you a story about that I mean
um the the recording messed up so when
we were interviewing him we were only
getting bits and pieces and we had to
deep fake him we had to we had to
regenerate uh the interview oh really
and he was saying in the entire
interview how much he hated deep
learning and how useless it was and then
um we we used deep learning to rescue
his interview and he gave it absolutely
literally did that yeah she tell him
yeah and he gave us his permission to
publish it that is wonderful so it's
quite ironic but no he always says it
it's um wonderful for engineering but
not a contribution to science yes sure
yeah
yeah he said I like bulldozers too
they're good for clearing the snow but
they're not a contribution design so so
who else have you I mean you've had a
lot of people on I listened to Andrew's
one by the way it's Andrew lampinen yes
he's great so he's great so Andrew
somebody I I do work with quite closely
oh wonderful um so uh it was interesting
listening to to him because Andrew had
quite a big influence on this paper by
the way oh okay um uh and I mean you
know and but I think I might have had a
bit of influence on him as well
listening to I guess so because that
interview was
just after he'd read and he read my
paper and gave me lots of comments and
we had a lot of discussion about it and
uh and that interview uh looking at the
recording date was was sort of just
after this and um and it's interesting I
mean he was very circumspect and in some
of the things he said yeah it was very
interesting because he uh I I think the
influences maybe gone both ways yes
which is which is nice uh I don't know I
mean I'm not I can't be sure of that but
I think there's a huge similarity yeah I
was thinking that actually just when you
were speaking but it's funny because you
know because we've
spent a lot of time arguing with each
other about and you know and I often
feel like we're we're coming from very
different perspectives on on this but in
fact you know I think there's
there's convergence really
what are your areas of disagreement
um
well you see I I would have thought
that Andrew would have been more on the
side of you know we can do things
without embodiment and without grounding
or or to kind of take grounding in a you
know
uh in a more liberal sense
um because because some people would
take that you know talk about grounding
so they say well you know that large
language models
they are grounded prompt engineering is
the process of uh using prompt prefixes
to allow llms to understand better
um you know so the the context and the
purpose of a conversation in order to
generate more appropriate responses
what do you think is going on with
prompt engineering Yeah well yeah so so
you let's probably let's slip a phrase
there it's of the process of allowing
the models to understand better is what
you bet of course I don't think guilty
as charged I don't think I don't think
that's the right way of characterizing
it as uh at all Yes
um
so
um I mean I think it's the whole thing
of prompt engineering is utterly
fascinating and and it's it's something
that's entered our world as AI
researchers very prominently just in the
last two years and it's amazing I I
um of course we have prompt Engineering
in the context of large language models
we also have prompt Engineering in the
context of the of you know the
generative uh image models as well like
Dali and so on and um and and that's
really fascinating as well how how by by
uh you know engineering the prompt to be
just the right sort of thing you can
coach the the model into doing something
which you know you might not otherwise
do and it and it's a and it's a great
example of how alien these things are
because if you were giving a human being
the same instructions then you wouldn't
necessarily do quite what you do with uh
with with either an llm or or an image
model in order to get it to do the thing
that you want it to do you have to kind
of you have to kind of get into the Zone
with these models and and figure out
kind of what strange incantations are
going to make it do the things that you
want it to do now I think an interesting
thing is that we may be looking at a
moment of a very short moment in the
history of the field where prompt
engineering is relevant because if if if
language models become good enough then
then you know we're not going to need to
talk to them in this weird way or you
know engineer the prompt to get them to
do what we want them to do is going to
be you know it's going to be a lot
easier but anyway so maybe that'll be
the case I mean that makes a lot of
sense that that will be the case as they
get better but at the moment
um you know you you you you can use a
strange incantation like thinking steps
and uh and suddenly the large language
model will will be much more effective
on reasoning problems than it was if you
didn't use the incantation thinking
steps so that's really fascinating so
what's going on there well I mean I
think what's going on there is that I
mean we have to again bear in mind that
what the model is really trained to do
is to his next word uh next word
prediction but we have to remember that
it's doing next word prediction in this
unimaginably complex distribution so and
and it's and it's it's not just we have
to remember that it's not just the
distribution of what a single human
would you know the distribution of the
sequence of words that a single human
will come out with but of all the sort
of text of of you know millions of
humans uh uh you know on the internet
plus actually a load of other stuff like
code and things which you know we don't
come out with in ordinary everyday
language or well people do it deepmind a
bit but you know that's deep
um uh so so it's it's this unimaginably
complex distribution and so I think
what's happening um uh with with with
prompt engineering is that you're you're
sort of
you know you're kind of channeling it
into some portion of the distribution so
you're you're queuing it up you know in
with with the with the with the prompt
and you're you're you're this kind of
context is putting it into some portion
of this distribution and that is what's
going to uh enable it to do something
different than it than it would have
done if you had a different set of words
and and that would have put it in a
different part of the distribution so
you're kind of finding the bit of this
in unimaginably complex distribution
you're finding the bit of it that you
want to then concentrate on yeah so in
intuitively I agree because I think
there's two ways of looking at this so
in I agree with you that they are
statistical language models I'm also a
fan of the spline theory of neural
networks which is this idea that you
just kind of um tessellate the ambient
space into these little
um affine polyhedra and it's a little
bit like a locality sensitive hashing
table but that's quite it's a quite a
simple way of looking at it because you
were talking about emergence before and
emergence is all about this paradigmatic
surprise a bit like the Mind Body
dualism them if you like there's
something that happens up here which is
paradigmatically completely different to
what happens down there so on the one
hand we're kind of saying oh they're
just simple
interpolators or statistical models but
on the other hand they really are doing
something remarkable up here so so which
is it which is it well I mean it's both
right so
um uh so so so you know if we want to
understand
uh these models in a in a in a more
scientific way which which we surely do
you know even if we're not even if we're
not engineering them in an old-fashioned
sense of engineering them but but rather
they kind of uh you know emerge from the
from the learning process but we still
want to reverse engineer them to try and
get as great as as as comprehensive a
scientific understanding of these things
as possible so so we want to understand
at all these levels right we of course
the foundation of that understanding is
that we need to understand the actual
mechanisms that we've programmed in
there right so though you know so you've
That's essential you want to you know if
you want to really understand these
things you've got to understand uh
Transformer architectures the different
kinds of Transformer architectures that
you've got the you know what happens
when you use kind of different parameter
settings whether it's sparse or dense
whether it's a decoder only architecture
or how you're doing the tokenization how
you're doing the embedding when all of
these things are essential to
understanding you know and that's all at
the absolutely at the engineering level
so we want to understand all of that but
then we can do a whole load of reverse
engineering at you know at another level
and do the sort of thing that the people
at anthropic AI have done for example
um with uh with these induction heads
and and and understanding in terms of uh
Transformers in terms of residual
streams and induction heads which I
think is fabulous work so that kind of
thing is is looking it's still at quite
a low level but it's kind of the next
level up uh and explaining a little bit
about how these things work and work
along those lines I think is like really
essential and then the more complex
these things are the the you know the
the heart the more we need to kind of
Ascend these levels of understanding and
and uh
um uh and and you know and I hope that
we can but I mean there's no one that is
the right one it's you want to
understand the things at all levels yeah
different levels of description
um you said something before which
really interested me you said when the
language models get good enough
um maybe we won't need the prompts
anymore and I'd love to explore that
Duality because um it's a similar
duality to how we talk about embodiment
you know you can think of the language
model being embodied in the prompt in in
some sense so maybe we'll never get rid
of the prompt but just to think about
these problems I think about them as a
new type of program interpreter and
there are some remarkable examples of
scratch pad and Chain of Thought and
even algorithmic prompting for getting
insane extrapolative performance on lots
of you know standard reasoning tasks
yeah yeah and you know these these
models are not Turing machines they're
finite State automotives so there are
limits to what we can do but I guess
what I'm saying is the prompt seems like
it's not going away anytime soon yeah so
I I think that I don't think the prompt
is going to go away but I think that you
know who knows right but but I think
that prompt engineering as a whole kind
of thing in itself you know may it may
not be you know people talk about that
as being a kind of a whole new job
description here as prompt engineer and
that so that that as a whole new job
description I'm not quite sure how long
exactly that all of us because because
prompting may be just you know
interacting with the thing in a much
more natural
language way in the way we would with
another person right so you know I don't
I don't uh when I uh when I I don't have
to kind of think of some peculiar
incantation in order to uh uh you know
in order to get uh you know my
colleagues to kind of uh help me on on
something or to you know uh uh to cook a
meal together with somebody we do
obviously we just use our natural kind
of uh forms of communication I mean of
course of course it does involve you
know discussion and negotiation but it's
in this it's just the same as we use
with other humans right so so it may be
that that rather than it being a
peculiar thing in itself with all these
funny phrases that just work for
peculiar eccentric reasons that it may
be much more natural
amazing Professor Shanahan
thank you so much for joining us today
indeed and thank you for the invitation
it's been lots of fun absolute honor
absolute honor why